[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
all right and we are live more cognito
here i love podcasting.net
and who is this fine gentleman that we
have in the realm of pax west today i'm
david brand marketing manager on gun
great core
this one has i've had my eye on
i want to jump right into it
there's a lot i want to talk and discuss
so let's get into what this gun very
boring
i mean do you know the previous gun game
right now that's why i want you to
educate me tell us all around
what is going great gorbachev so
gungrave gore released back in 2006 like
there was two games back then published
by activision
and we're pretty much
reimagining
those games in a way like you know kind
of new now
it's developed by a studio called iggy
mob in south korea south korea but we
still have like the original creator on
board as well which is the other hero
night tool you might know him from the
anime tri-gun yeah for example which was
quite the popular enemy and he also did
the gun great pretty much it started as
a game back with activision and
also adapted to an anime as well
and he's on board
like it was a game first and then
adapted to anime as nice nice
yeah and like we have gore in the name
you can see it already starts quite gory
as well
okay we getting into it early
okay
all right let's go cover it and it's the
main protagonist this is our guy exactly
the gun grave or what is he he's called
grave so he's actually
dead or undead so to say
certain mechanics that keep him alive
and he's like on a on a road to
vengeance pretty much
so people who are familiar with the old
games back in the day they will see
certain things that are familiar with
like it's uh it's kind of a continuation
of the story back then but also you know
a lot of newcomers will also actually um
you know get the story from playing this
one first and we actually also have a
defined gap like a recap of what
happened what happened the guy's like
completely fresh into the game you can
pretty much uh watch that recap and you
know get the whole idea of one number
one check the ass i i just i like the
like the mystery structure that's how it
was in the previous game as well and i
mean we gotta keep that right so i mean
i'm going to skip the tutorials
regularly now
so what you got to do once you skip this
is what the hell is this so this is
actually his coffin
it doesn't really look like a coffin but
it is one trust me and he can actually
use that for different abilities you
will see that later in the game where we
actually unlock the abilities and the
whole purpose of the game is pretty much
just you know kind of mindless fun i
would say just go crazy with crazy
abilities we wanted to be wanted this
game to be as easy to pick up as
possible
and uh yeah just pretty much going full
crazy oh crazy full tell now the
question is let's talk about this meter
up here yes
so on the upper left uh we will pretty
much unlock this in the next step you
will see ability points that can be used
and to do pretty over the top
as well
we will see that in a bit it will unlock
like after a few minutes no worries
in progress
and then we got the beats going so i'm
assuming continuous kills meticulous
fight exactly exactly think of it as
like a combo meter as well um
in the final game after each stage you
will have like a result screen
showcasing you kind of how you perform
you know
giving on how high your beat was you
will actually also unlock different
skills that we can also showcase in a
bit
but like think of it as a combo video
okay
so yeah and then of course we can also
reflect
oh
this is the first level of the game
first area of the game so you know
for this demo
in particular we actually gave the
players way more abilities so you know
we can go over the top as well we will
see that in a bit but in the final game
you will actually
have like progression into the game like
with the experience point capability
point that you can use fair enough fair
enough yeah it looks really fantastic
love love the fact that the creativity
and again it doesn't take itself too
seriously but at the other day it's
about me it looks like it's about being
stylish yes
i mean there's even like rules
there's like a
how you perform like over the top moves
as well like those also account at the
result screen on how well you perform so
you will also have like a ranking system
with s being like the best rank possible
you know as we go on in the game we will
learn different abilities we'll go a
little differently and like speaking of
the abilities this is where we actually
are locking them right now as we speak
exactly right
so as you see i have now
five ability points
[Music]
the way the ability points work is that
we were actually building up this bar
the more we hit people the more the beat
goes up and that's how we will actually
get the ability points to use and i mean
i can show you something else
as i said like over the top that's all
we got completely over the top
again you said the original game
came out this is not an extension of
that or something the team may have
learned from the first game to the
second so the the
what the first games were kind of
lacking were like like oh some of those
over the top
that we're seeing right now and we will
see one later which is called storm
mirage
that's really going all over the top and
that's what the team pretty much aimed
for you know learning or pretty much
what what the base games have and just
going over the top on the top yeah
pretty much that
engine wire was done great music it's
unreal engine four
wheels in the building
you gotta get the fast get out from the
shield guys
white ghost-like steak that's when you
can do the finishing exactly
that's what you can finish
nice
nice
now how's it going
yes we will actually see a boss at the
end of this demo
and
they also get over the top as we
progress
we have one boss in this build
he's like kind of your starting boss you
know to get used to this but like as
soon as you progress more on the game
you get even more crazier bosses and you
can actually see some of them we've
recently released the trailer with
showcasing some of the like your main
enemies
and that gives you like a little bit of
a taste of what has come
and as the game goes on you're talking
about balls you're talking about the
stylus actually like if you wanted to
have uh anything i know you're not
taking yourself too seriously but is it
going to have any of any narrative yes
like as you can see we already have like
cutscene there is a story behind it
and fans of the game and of the anime
will actually you know understand what's
happening um but for someone you know
who's not really into the story you
don't care for the story right yeah but
i don't know that's that's like that's
also quite like you know
and as you can see that's the art points
as well they they help you on the result
screen as well for you know
kind of your
install on how you perform
speaking of more abilities we're getting
more now we're going into the crazy
graphs
like we can also use one as a human
shield for it oh let's go we can throw
them at someone
let's get it so really over the top yeah
yes this is what i'm talking about so
you guys thought of modest which you can
see but as i can see it's a ramp up yes
there's so much more going on and as i
said you know like for this specific
build we already unlocked some of the
abilities but the in the final game like
you have like a wide array of different
abilities that you can unlock
you can pretty much mix and match how
you would like to prefer to play as well
now with the beat system and maintaining
that in the style of this at the end of
levels is um there's literally something
like that kind of rewards the player
that doesn't get hit a lot that is doing
all this stylish stuff yeah so we will
actually unlock you know more ability
points but also like if you play on
different difficulty settings you will
actually unlock skins as well for for
the game and those are really awesome
for the fans because some of them
actually go back to like the old
callbacks exactly exactly and we for
example we've also worked with uh
ikomina
who you might know from like the um
tokyo yes example she also created her
own new studio
but she worked like on the art direction
for this game as well and we actually
have a skin that she created as well
for the game
i love it
are the harpy with the execution that
was the rv
exactly
and what i love is like a love letter to
clearly fit into the series you have
those call backs yeah you have those
things
like one of the skins as well that you
can unlock it's like the od grave that's
like the overdrive spray from back in
the days as well
this looks really good and then also for
fans of the series we have some
unannounced characters that you can play
as well so yeah if you look forward you
know to some news
in the next coming weeks
people can get excited for them
that's the storm
if you
beat hit
50
like if you think of like equilibrium
for example as well yes
those john wounds those those like this
is this is a style of game and art style
you don't see a lot of exactly it's so
cool to see it come back in game form
and to know that it has a history
you know as far as the original gun
grave and it being you know adapted its
enemy is pretty cool as well
moving on moving on even more moves now
the first move that's happening in my
mind
oh
much show you where to go next
nice so as far as like total loan
protection like what are we looking at
anticipating for like let's like before
so i can't go into too much detail of
how many levels we actually have but
like the game is going to take you like
roughly 15 to 20 hours to finish and
there's a lot of variety in the levels
as well so it will not only be like in a
factory like we're currently like
there's also like a jungle area we've
got different bio exactly exactly
over the top places as well i love it i
love it i ain't got to be stuck at the
factory all day little different places
as well for example
one of the
one of the locations also the influence
by vietnam for example like there's like
different influences for the locations
as well
and we're slowly approaching the bus
right now man that's what we want to see
want to see that
almost there there's a lot of tension in
this factory a lot of just going
i like that
[Music]
some destructible environment yes so we
have uh you know certain things that you
can shoot at where barrels that explode
uh crates that i have
kind of like i just showed you
so yeah there's like environmental
destruction as well like you can see
here
love the characters
as well
let's go
oh so
like the boss has big points as well
yeah exactly i'm assuming the movement
would have gotten a little crazy
you showed up expert level
just like that's what i'm that's what
i'm trying this is not how it would go
down if it was me
he's targeting this thing correctly
a little bit of a rocket launcher
let's
there we go
and it's our demo for gun great score
gun grave
flashy over the top stylish action
variety cinematics looks really really
cool how far are out from release and
what platforms can we get so we're
releasing in november 22nd uh platforms
all platforms except nintendo switch so
playstation 4 plays h5 xbox one series
kitchen and pc exactly
with smart delivery as well and like the
ps4 free upgrade is five as well oh
that's awesome that's awesome
question for my home
my steam deck owners i know baby early
but you know this game that
so we're currently looking into steam
deck as well that you you know like it's
supported from the get-go anyways but
like optimizing it for steam deck we're
currently looking into that that's
awesome good grade your sword here first
iot approved lord cognito we had an
absolute pleasure man it looks really
fun tell the team i'm excited
i'm very excited man you said it first
gun grave
[Music]
you